how's it going everybody it's Warren and
a ton of you have been asking me about
the leaked Avengers and game footage
that has been going around everywhere
online a lot of you have been asking me
why am I not talking about it especially
since I talked about leaks and spoilers
quite frequently on my channel well I
haven't actually seen the footage and I
don't want to I've seen about two
seconds of it because a lot of people
have been sending it to me and have been
tagging me and posts that have the video
in it and some people have tweeted at me
telling me what it's about so I know a
little bit about it but I haven't seen
it yet and I don't plan on watching it
and for those of you who are wondering
what it is and haven't seen it yet and
don't want to see it either I'll explain
what it is with no spoilers so basically
what happened is that Marvel sent the
film off somewhere to get translated
obviously there are many many different
languages all throughout the world and
all these people need it translated so
they can understand the movie well an
employee for one of the companies that
was hired to translate the film secretly
video recorded the last five minutes of
the movie along with other major scenes
of Avengers endgame so that's what the
leaked footage is that's going around
right now literally the last five
minutes of the movie and major scenes
from the movie I personally don't want
to see this thank you to everybody who
has sent me the video I can totally
understand why you would think that I
would want to see this and talk about it
for me
I don't want Avengers in game the film
that I have been waiting for and
millions of people have been waiting for
for a very long time the movie that is
supposed to wrap up the first 11 years
of the MCU I don't want that final
moment that ending of the first 11 years
of the MCU ruined for me by a clip
online I understand everybody takes
spoilers a different way this clip may
not even face people and may even get
them more excited to see Avengers in
game that's awesome I'm happy for you
but I would be totally bummed out if I
saw it yes I love to talk about leaks I
love to talk about spoilers but not the
ending of a movie that I've been waiting
11 years to see and to me there is a
difference between say actors saying
that oh the dead heroes are going to
come back and Avengers in game okay well
yeah we knew that it's exciting to hear
them say that but at the same time
Doctor Strange spider-man black panther
guardians of the galaxy they all have
sequels coming up in the future so we
know they're gonna come back somehow so
does it really ruin anything
there was a toy leak last week that had
another Infinity Gauntlet in it and if
the toy leak is real the Avengers will
make their own Infinity Gauntlet but at
the same time okay we really knew that
as well because either the Infinity
Gauntlet is not damaged and Thanos can
use its full power which means the
Avengers are never going to get it from
him
so of course they'll have to make their
own or the gauntlet is damaged and they
can't use it so again they'd have to
make their own so yes it was a big toy
leak but did it really ruin anything no
not really
but it's fun and it's exciting to
speculate and theorize and find these
leaks and these spoilers that's what I
want my channel to be about not actually
ruining the ending of a movie so for
those of you who wanted me to break down
the footage I'm sorry and from the two
seconds that I saw it looks amazing but
we have less than a week until Avengers
end game hits theaters and I don't want
anything spoiled for me I can say from
the two seconds that I saw and from what
people have been telling me if you've
been with my channel for a while some of
the things that we've been speculating
about and theorizing about are accurate
so I'm super excited to see Avengers in
game in less than a week now so again
thank you to everybody who has sent me
this footage I'm not going to watch it
because I don't want anything about
Avengers in game ruined for me but for
those of you who do want to watch it
just google it it's really not that hard
to find and it's all over Twitter and
Instagram so if you don't want to be
spoiled by this footage I suggest
staying off of it until Avengers end
game hits theaters and you can watch it
again a lot of you have been asking me
why I haven't covered this footage
especially since I talked about leaks
and spoilers a lot on my channel and if
it was other footage other than the
ending I might but I don't want it
written for me there's only six more
days until we can see it in America and
some other countries there are even less
days so just sit tight we're in the
endgame now as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]